hier hat meine damen und herren wir sind
bild weil bilder oft mehr sagen als
tausend worte bei diesem bild hier von
olaf scholz gestern bei seinem
dreistündigen antrittsbesuch bei us
präsident joe biden im waisenhaus und
müssen wir beide sandra und noch kaum
gehen um die nähe und behaglichkeit die
die beiden ausstrahlen wollen nicht zu
stören so entstehen beziehungsweise
sitzen sie in der ukraine krise zusammen
da passt kein blatt dazwischen war die
botschaft an putin und erst recht keine
zwei moderatoren das stimmt thomas ich
komme wieder ein bisschen rein ins bild
denn zur gleichen zeit in moskau hier
sehen wir es frankreichs präsident
trifft russlands voting ja und die
beiden sind rein rücken definitiv kommen
wir hier ein bisschen an mich ran ja die
beiden sind so weit voneinander entfernt
auch in ihren politischen positionen
dass wir uns locker dazwischen stellen
können immerhin fast sechs stunden lang
sprachen die beiden über die ukraine
krise und äußerten sich danach ganz
vorsichtig optimistisch aber kann man
dem trauen denn ebenfalls gestern
entstand dieses bild wir rücken wieder
etwas sagte die lunge oder das was davon
die mir putin verlässt fluchtartig
geradezu die werft blohm & voss in
hamburg offenbar hat putin angst dass
sie im falle eines angriffs auf die
ukraine im zuge von sanktionen
beschlagnahmt werden könnte das zeugt
nicht von friedlichen absichten also der
erste besuch von olaf scholz als neuer
deutscher bundeskanzler in washington
und das in krisenzeiten dann schauen wir
uns mal an welchen eindruck er auf
dieser großen weltbühnen hinterlassen
haben das wollen wir tun gemeinsam mit
béla anda wir analysieren zusammen dem
ehemaligen regierungssprecher unter
bundeskanzler schröder bela hallo schön
dass du da bist ja du warst oft bei
besuchen im weißen haus dabei wie läuft
das denn hinter den kulissen eigentlich
ab
zum besuch im weißen haus ist schon sehr
sehr eine sehr angespannte situation
weil man redet schließlich mit dem immer
noch mächtigsten menschen der welt das
ist jedem der politisch handelt gerade
auch olaf scholz im bewusstsein team das
ihn begleitet ebenso also da zählt ja
mehr als sonst noch jedes wort jede
geste insofern geht man da rein mit
einer mischung aus euphorie weil es ist
ja schließlich das 2 da raus und wir
jeden neu kann es ist es das erste mal
im openoffice und
anspannung auch den ihr geht es ja um
was und man wird dann diebe haben das
hier gezeigte an der seite an einem
seiteneingang der berühmt ist
vorgefahren dort warten dann die beiden
navy seals und die marien officer und
begrüßen ein ziemlich dann wird man ihn
eingeleitet meistens durch einen
assistenten oder eines ist antin und
dann geht es durch ein paar hallen davor
den meisten muss man auch noch ein paar
minuten warten bis ich dann irgendwo man
hat ja keine orientierung war ja noch
nie im weißen haus eine tür öffnet und
wo steht man wirklich plötzlich in
diesem heiligtum dem oval office das für
viele reporter die dabei waren wissen
dass kleiner wirkt als es auf den
fernsehbildern zu sehen ist und dann
geht's schon los man sitzt wie olaf
scholz unter einem bild von rm lincoln
und denkt natürlich an alles was mit
diesem office assoziiert wird und ja und
dann gibt es ein paar fragen und es
beginnt das gespräch dann haben wir doch
mal rein bilder in die pressekonferenz
von den beiden und putin und du sagst
was der auf
beiden und putin oder komplett verlernt
hat weiß man schon mal vergessen daran
habe ich keinen zweifel
absolutely united eine bibel not taking
defence tabs wenn es zu einer
militärischen aggression gegen die
ukraine kommt dann wird es harte
gemeinsam vereinbarte und weitreichende
sanktionen geben das wird sehr sehr hohe
kosten für russland haben an solchen
schritt zu tun
willkommen wir freuen uns kanzler
stolziert zu haben das erste mal im
weißen haus es ist toll dass das
stattfindet
danke dass ich hier sein darf ich freue
mich dass wir die möglichkeit haben all
die wichtigen dinge zu besprechen
also weiter und schoss mit reiten und
putin natürlich wähle dein eindruck
clips die hier gezeigte zeigen natürlich
ein hohes maß an übereinkunft
übereinstimmung für mich interessant wer
sich die ganze pressekonferenz anguckt
dann hört man schon sagen ja wir machen
das alles hand in hand und ganz genau
wir stehen fest an der seite und
entzieht der drei dinge auf die beiden
nie erwähnt hat nämlich den
nato-russland-rat die osze also die
organisation für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa und das nochmal
die format also das format bei
deutschland frankreich die ukraine und
russland zusammen sitzen und sagt das
werden wir weiter nutzen also eher
bestärkt beiden aber selbst da in diesen
anderen ausschnitten auch ganz eigene
akzente dass er sagt dass sie mir kommt
es auch weiter darauf an darauf an im
dialog zu sein trotz der krise die
dekade haben sehr selbstbewusst und für
mich erstaunlich dass er so tatsächlich
selbstbewusster aufgetreten ist und
anschließend lieber bela ist scholz noch
zu cnn gegangen und hat dort ein
interview auf englisch gegeben das gab
so auch noch nie da haben wir auch noch
mal kurz rein und untertiteln das nur in
deutsch damit wir mal hören wie gut
scholz eigentlich englisch spricht und
dubina ordners danach wieder ein
ökonomisch resilienz auf die ukraine 1
an der hand absolutely working
to create
absolutely zu gaddafi
starb stadtbibliothek dann
mal abgesehen vom inhaltlichen vom
politischen bela da ist ein deutscher
bundeskanzler der bei ciena im großen
nachrichtensender live auftritt und auf
englisch sehr gut pariert
ja ich hatte mal wieder ein interview
bei george stephanopoulos
bbc vermittelt das koste aber damals
übersetzt wird tatsächlich
beeindruckend wie olaf scholz das
spricht gut heute zu tage ist es ja so
dass man das von führenden
politikerinnen und politiker erwarten
darf aber tatsächlich auch angela merkel
hat im übrigen sehr sehr gut englisch
gesprochen wer also dazu auch in der
lage gewesen aber schon beeindruckt bei
scholz hat man das nicht so
ist also ich zumindest nicht und
deswegen ist das natürlich auch
soundbite sound tipps für den
amerikanischen markt produziert hat wer
glaubst du denn olaf scholz konnte damit
auch seinen bekanntheitsgrad in den usa
etwas steigern meinst du die menschen
kennen ihn auch schon
naja also da muss man wirklich er nicht
sein wenn ein deutscher bundeskanzler
nach amerika kommt dann interessiert das
sicherlich die politische klasse und vor
allen dingen die wir washington aber es
schon wenn man 200 oder 100 kilometer
weiter westwärts fährt da auch eine
pferde farben geht und da jemanden
fragen
sagte einem us show man muss das
verstehen wir sind da in deutschland
trotz dieses krieges nicht das center of
attention war für die ist wahrscheinlich
angela merkel nach bundeskanzlerin für
die meisten wir sind mal ein paar
hundert kilometer weiter gegangen nicht
aufs land aber nördliche richtungen new
york und unser korrespondent herbert
bauernebel der haben wir dieses foto von
olaf scholz aus dem flieger im
genommen und hatte sowie gezeigt und hat
gefragt ob sie eine ahnung haben wenn
das wohl sein könnte hier spricht das
volk und in diesem fall das
amerikanische werden
[Musik]
angela merkel war 16 jahre an der macht
viele menschen hier in amerika haben sie
natürlich gekannt ihr nachfolger ist
hier weniger bekannt in den usa
natürlich ja ist erst seit kurzem im amt
wir haben einen kleinen test gemacht
während sich der deutsche kanzler mit
dem amerikanischen präsidenten getroffen
hat in den straßen von new york wir
haben ein foto mitgebracht von kanzler
olaf scholz und haben die amerikaner
befragt ob sie ihn kennen wir sehen dass
mehren bevor
what
can you imagine lassen
[Musik]
ja bilder an also immer noch bei uns
bilder also er könnte ein manager sein
so im schlabberlook er könnte aber auch
im web unterwegs sein wir wollen uns mal
ein paar bilder nochmal anschauen bilder
und ich möchte mit dir darüber sprechen
also das ist das berühmte foto von olaf
scholz im flieger in washington jetzt
habe béla anda gerade aus der leitung
verloren habe ich gehört aber wir
schauen uns die bilder trotzdem an jetzt
vielleicht schon das berühmteste foto
von olaf scholz und man sieht er ist gut
gelaunt hier im schlabberlook als
politiker so zu sagen wir haben auch
bilder von anderen kanzler gerhard
schröder beispielsweise auch ganz leger
aufgetreten im flieger da gehen dann die
politiker immer von vorne nach hinten in
die kabine hinein und sprechen mit den
journalisten geben sich da ganz volksnah
sind auch so ein bisschen hintergrund
gespräche die wir geführt werden und da
sehen wir unter anderem auch hier in dem
nächsten foto sehen wir zeigt mal da
gerade auf ihn das ist béla anda mit dem
wir gerade gesprochen haben in der zeit
als er der regierungssprecher von
gerhard schröder war beziehungsweise der
ganzen regierung unter gerhard schröder
angela merkel kennen wir die ist immer
in ihrem kanzler outfit unterwegs
gewesen auch wenn sie im flugzeug war
helmut kohl dagegen können wir sehen der
es auch ein bisschen leser aufgetreten
genscher natürlich in seinem pool unter
auf eine in diesem fall nicht gelb war
auf diesem schwarz weiß wo du jedenfalls
also cool da auch immer leger und das
hat natürlich gründe meine damen und
herren kein foto entsteht ohne dass man
vorher darüber nachgedacht hat wie sich
die politiker geben und gerade im fall
kohl wir erinnern uns alle auch an das
berühmte foto zusammen mit gorbatschow
als er mit der strickjacke aufgetreten
ist das war im juli 1990 als es darum
ging um die wiedervereinigung nach dem
fall der mauer und deutschland seine
souveränität zurück bekommen hat das
geeinte deutschland da waren die beiden
auf der datscha helmut kohl da auch in
der strickjacke und da sollte eben
betont werden dass man sich auf eine
besondere
sauberkeit geeinigt hat und so eben eine
besondere atmosphäre entstanden ist also
dass die berühmten fotos aus den
fliegern olaf scholz jetzt schon berühmt
geworden mit diesem foto hier auf dem
weg nach washington